tras ser acusado de tener vínculos con
Rusia un juez ordenó el arresto
domiciliario en contra del metropolita
Pablo un representante de la iglesia
ortodoxa luego de que las autoridades le
siguieran el rastro por supuestamente
justificar la invasión rusa
el juez de instrucción decidió imponer
al sospechoso Metropolitan Pablo una
medida de restricción en forma de
arresto domiciliario por un plazo de 60
días
la orden judicial fue emitida después de
que el servicio de seguridad de Ucrania
allanara la casa del jerarca ortodoxo y
publicará conversaciones en las que el
monje celebraba la ocupación rusa de
gerson El metropolita Pablo pertenece a
la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana del
patriarcado de Moscú una especie de
filial de la iglesia ortodoxa rusa en
Ucrania que rompió relaciones con su
iglesia madre el pasado mayo luego de
conocerse el apoyo del patriarca ruso
kiril a la guerra las autoridades
ucranianas consideran a la iglesia
ortodoxa ucraniana del patriarcado de
Moscú como un foco de influ encia rusa
en el país
es triste que los fiscales hayan hecho
esto
bueno Dios mismo se encargará de ellos
esta es una orden política no hice nada
malo me dijeron que fuera a la iglesia
ortodoxa de Ucrania me negué me
amenazaron
a las afueras del monasterio de las
cuevas se vivieron manifestaciones tanto
de rechazo como de apoyo a la decisión
dictada por el juez hasta el momento 61
curas han sido capturados por
acusaciones similares siete de ellos
condenados y dos enviados a Rusia
durante un intercambio de prisioneros